this program brought to you by
mercedes-benz the Mercedes AMG and the
all-new GT 4-door coupe because life is
a race visit your local dealership test
drive today if you missed any of the
interviews from the Mercedes AMG mancave
go to the Dan Patrick show app watch and
listen from inside the Mercedes AMG
mancave Mercedes AMG driving performance
he is the ultra tight end for the San
Francisco 49ers he's George Kittel who
joins us on the program George good
morning thanks for joining us how are
you I'm excellent thanks so much for
having me how you doing how're you
feeling feeling great kidding me well
you came back from the injury I didn't
know if after you play if you know
you're banged up or you still feel it
honestly I think I'm just more sort of
for missing out in a couple weeks and
not being hit so you know his shoulders
legs are just sore from that but you
know overall just ready to roll
did you watch the game last night I did
they're pretty good now are you more
interested in watching Lamar Jackson as
as a viewer or are you watching the
Ravens defense because you have to go up
against them next game uh well watching
the mark Jackson's pretty special
there's not really no one that does what
he does um you know just their office in
general it was really fun I was watching
it last night with Fred Warner and so I
was asking them you know hey man you
know what are your thoughts and he was
like you know what I'm just gonna I'm
gonna wait till Wednesday where we have
our game plan set up yeah you don't want
to ruin his night because he's got to be
thinking oh my god and then how do you
how do you replicate that George in
practice who's going to play the role
Lamar Jackson for the for your defense
um you know I don't know probably I mean
I don't know cuz you do it all you can't
really put a lot of Seaver there cuz you
need someone I could throw the ball in
ki can and you know that's why I'm not a
coach and I just kind of show up to work
every day and deal with what they give
me I don't to make those decisions
who do you pattern yourself after Seguin
SAR who do you pattern yourself after as
a player um I don't know I think I just
kind of try to take from as many
different as I can see and just know I
watch everyone on film and stuff like
that I just try to take little tidbits
from everybody and you know what just
try to see you know try to make what
works for me you know go and
whether that's a run blocking stuff from
certain guys or receiving stuff from
other guys I just try to get a little
bit from everybody will give me some
names here George oh I'm sorry
let's see I mean I don't think you could
watch enough you know Bronx tone that's
one one person I you know I kind of grew
up watching especially in college I
watched a ton of his film I always loved
watching a hunter Henry I watched a
bunch of him when he was in Arkansas -
when I was in college but especially now
you can't ever watched enough Travis
Kelce I mean there's obviously there's
so many good tight ends in this league I
have a list of guys that go through
almost every single week and I mean they
all do such incredible things so I just
try to get a little bit from all of them
more important flirty last night I like
watching Mark Andrews he's fun to watch
- yeah they got a couple of tight ends
on that team but more more important
footwork or your hands as a tight end in
a run game or pass game well just
overall whoo Wow uh-huh whoo that's a
tough one I I'm a big believer of you
know your footwork because you know if
you can get open you can probably catch
the ball in the running game you know if
you have a good footwork then you don't
really have to have that good his hands
as long as you have good pad placement
and you got inside arms and so I'm a big
believer in the good footwork that's one
thing that's definitely elevated in my
game in the last two years what happens
when you have the ball that nobody's
around you like it feels like that gets
that's tougher than the tough catches
just does that make sense we're the ones
yeah no I trust me yeah yeah so that's
that's the thing have you had one of
those moments where it was just too easy
and you dropped it
I yeah I know I mean I had one my rookie
year I had a shallow I - shallow for the
probably events like 40 yards and a
touchdown against the Cardinals and I
just let bounce off my hips that was a
fun one
thanks for bringing out what's it like
during film session when that comes you
know what's coming what's it like yeah
not fun it's just kind of like well you
know it's you just got to make the play
I mean that's really all it is and no
luckily my talent coach John Embry is
not uh he's not too much of oh you know
gets in your face and stuff like that
he's like hey look at you so we put you
in a position to make the play you just
got to go make it and so
but luckily haven't had to hear those
since then when did you know you were
good and I thought I was good when I was
playing catch in the backyard with my
dad like the age of three okay so I mean
that's just kind of a dream always I was
you know playing in SL and so I just did
everything I could
don't get to that and you know whether
it was practicing lifting weights
running or whatever it was everything
that I did was towards my goal of
playing in the NFL and I think just kind
of those you know hard-working those
characteristics just kind of helped me
out along the way well you went to high
school in Norman Oklahoma right yeah but
you went to Iowa yeah what happened oh
my dad played in Iowa okay but you
didn't you didn't want to stay at home
no I mean I was kind of always a dream
school for me okay I lived in Iowa City
for like I think like eight years so I
mean I grew up at home I'd see the
tickets to Iowa games and Kinnick
Stadium back when Dallas Clark was
playing Bob Stander's I mean I got a
hide season tickets I think until like
2007 okay because I know your dad was on
what the 82 Rose Bowl team he was yeah
yeah who's the best athlete in the
family my mom probably we your wife was
she's a basketball player at Iowa right
she is my mom is actually high school
Hall of Fame for softball I love that
yeah so I'm gonna tip the cap to her
that's smart that that's probably the
right thing to do we're talking to
Georgia Kennedy Niners tight end you
graduated what was your degree
communications communications with a
minor in entrepreneurship all right what
are you gonna do with the communications
degree I'm gonna keep talking to you do
well I saw where your teammates roughed
you up a little bit where you got a lot
of camera time the other night and there
you're like the the the player version
of Jerry Jones is that what they're
calling you yeah I've heard that one a
couple times
he's funny actually I enjoy that one why
were you getting all the camera time
I mean Garoppolo is the good-looking guy
okay that's true that's true it's true
he is
no I think it's just because I might
make such a fool of myself up in the box
when I'm cheering for my guys it's hard
for me to hold back any emotion so I
might be entertaining to watch sometimes
do you make a fool out of yourself on
purpose no I just I just love the game
so much I just I sorta have to hold
anything back so whether that's you know
I I just enjoy it too much and so I
never really holding anything back well
it's been a great start and I think
people would sign up for Niners Ravens
right now for the Super Bowl that would
be pretty entertaining have fun watch
that too sure you have fun against the
Ravens that defense is you know people
are forgetting about the defense you
know they're talking about Lamar Jackson
that defense is good George yeah I know
I watched last night trust me I I did
not miss this thing they are a very
talented squad and I'm really looking
forward to see what we know we're going
to do against them well you're you're
really telling it tight end glad that
you're getting some exposure I know that
we in the media guilty of that East
Coast bias but you're everybody's good
as any tight in and the NFL and good
luck of the rest of the regular season
hey I appreciate that minute means a lot
coming from you so thank you so much
thanks for having me on that's George
Kittel the Niners site in for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR Live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]